you know
every time chris chibnall has done a new
year's special
i have been surprised at how much i
liked it and i am at this point
genuinely trying to figure out is it
because
i'm still getting over being drunk from
new year's eve is it because the finales
of all of his series have been so much
of a letdown and anything would be a
step up
or is he genuinely entertaining me don't
know if i have an answer for that but
let's talk about the latest one anyways
[Music]
eve of the daleks and yeah i kind of
gave it away or at least part of where
i'm going with this in the cold open i
enjoyed this
it shouldn't surprise me at this point i
enjoyed resolution i enjoyed revolution
of the daleks not without reservations
as is the case here as well and i
suspect that both of those are not going
to feel as good on a re-watch
but on initial viewing i enjoyed most of
what was going on in both of them and i
enjoy most of what's going on here and i
think i enjoy it more than either of
those two
i kind of feel like the specials bring
out the best
in him
and maybe it's because
so far
with his writing when he's written
standalones
they feel like filler and not just
because they don't contribute to some
sort of greater story series 11 didn't
really have one of those at all but they
don't even feel like they're moving the
characters forward in any significant
way and then when he does try and do
overarching stories
it has not worked for me at all but
there's something about him doing the
the new year specials where it's like
yes it's a self-contained story but it's
also going to be bigger it's going to
matter because it's a special and it's
longer and so it's like
he taps into that enthusiasm that he has
for the bigger stories without having
the space to actually do the stuff that
he does with like the overarching plots
that tend to take me off but it doesn't
feel as throwaway as his standalone
stuff it actually finds a decent balance
pretty consistently and again
yeah
i enjoy this
so there's a number of things uh that i
like about this like right off the bat
something happened that i was like oh
for god's sake and then
it amended my issues almost immediately
because when the first time uh nick died
oh uh spoilers i guess i'm gonna talk
about this pretty openly i enjoyed it
got some reservations can't even really
talk about those without getting into
spoilers so there you go so the first
time nick died i remember going oh for
god's sake
chip no you did it again
you did it again taking a minority
character and killing them off
pointlessly early in the freaking thing
you did it two years ago with resolution
with a gay character you're like and
they're gay and now they're dead and so
now you've done it with a person of
color
terrific and then the time loop restart
i was like
oh okay well never mind that um i don't
know if he meant to subvert himself on
that but he did a little bit on purpose
or by accident
there's a number of things i like about
this time loop
first of all it is kind of nice the
doctor who actually hasn't done time
loops
all that often um very much at all
really i mean heaven sent was
kind of a time loop but also technically
wasn't that one's
that one's weird in a number of ways and
there have been times that time has gone
back on itself but an actual loop you're
just starting you're just restarting the
day
there's a number of things about the way
this is done specifically that i really
like
for starters i actually kind of love
the whole thing about the time the time
loop gets shorter
every cycle
so that it means they can't just
groundhog day the thing
and just they have infinite tries to get
it right until they get it absolutely
perfect it still is able to give them
stakes
and something resembling a ticking clock
despite the fact that they know they are
going to get sent back to the time loop
but they're going to get more tries but
not an infinite number of tries that was
interesting i also like that not only
them but also the daleks
remember what's going on loop to loop so
that it's not just a matter of
fine-tuning this one thing until you get
it right but every time it's actually
going to be slightly different because
the daleks are going to behave
differently based off what they
saw you do last time and what they think
you're going to do this time
that was cool i thought that was a
really neat trick and i think we
actually get to know nick and sarah
pretty decently and they feel like more
fleshed out characters than
chibnall supporting characters often do
that said like i called immediately
nick's got a crush on her and that's a
very
stale honestly in my personal opinion
kind of dynamic to set them up with but
it also didn't bog it down the thing
moves at a good enough pace that while i
don't like that as a trope this whole
unrequited i've been pining at you
forever and you haven't noticed me
thing especially when it's a guy
pineapple girl which yeah they
acknowledge it's a little creepy but
then they also still
do it anyways
but again the thing moves quick enough
and the thing resets often enough that
that didn't really drag the whole thing
down that it might have in other
circumstances there's a fair number of
specific moments and littler things that
i like quite a bit as well for example i
actually really love that in one loop
nick destroys two daleks by ducking when
they fire at each other now normally i
would call bs on that but since they've
got the dollar so quick with like the
gatling gun it's gonna fire a heck of a
lot of shots before they realize what's
happened and just a loop before
when daleks had been on either side if i
forget who it was it might have been
sarah and shot her i remember thinking
boy
it's a good thing their aim was good
that time because yes we do have a
little bit of an instance of suddenly
their aim is bad because the story
demands the characters can't get shot in
this moment but i was like good thing
their aim was good because otherwise
they just would have blown each other up
and then the very next loop that
actually happened i was like hey
that wasn't just a random thing i
noticed
gymnal notice too
nice so there's little things like that
i like dan distracting the dalek a lot
for two reasons i love dan's attitude
and like this kind of odd triumph he has
when the dalek realizes that dan's just
there to distract him and jin just goes
took you long enough because
that was the point it took him a little
while to figure it out and plus it also
gave us this gem of line daleks do not
have managers
i don't know why i don't like it's kind
of dumb it's kind of a dumb line but i
honestly love it
doctors got a pretty good we're gonna
get this done speech um and part of it
is because she's not saying we
definitely got this next time it's like
look we're going to try we're going to
fail we're going to try and fail but
we're going to get a little bit better
every time until we win which while not
as um
perfect or as eloquent as peter
capaldi's um response to the master
saying you're not gonna win and just
going i know and like winning isn't the
point here winning is the point but it
felt somewhat evocative about that and
honestly i'd say it's probably her best
speech e moment since uh haunting a
villa dia daddy and i also honestly i
kind of love that the very next loop
that after she gave the big bet the big
pep talk very next loop they get
annihilated almost immediately
i like that they kind of undercut that
because yes the sentiment she's uh she's
talking about is going to get them
through this but just because she said a
rousing speech doesn't suddenly mean
that they win
they still got some stuff to deal with i
like that
and honestly i just feel like the whole
thing was a really good balance between
being just complicated enough to be
interesting but also just simple enough
to work as a fairly straightforward
roller coaster ride of an episode
it was
it was a good balance of those elements
i had a lot of fun with this
does that mean i absolutely love it it's
perfect no
of course it doesn't there's a number of
things that maybe go
there's little things like how long it
took that dalek to get through a door to
a storage unit which i mean the show did
actually kind of lampshade that and the
doctor uh had a very good put down line
of congratulations
you have defeated an old door so like
that helped but you still are kind of
hanging a lampshade on something that
was a little bit dumb you know what line
actually really bugged me
less because of uh its specific use here
more because of what it implies
uh dan telling the doctor you saved the
whole universe last week implying that
at the end of flux everybody saved but
you know the end of flux didn't
establish
that
like we did not see and they did not
explicitly lay out that all the
destruction that we saw wrought that
bell was going through trying to find
vendor all these destroyed planets all
these ruined systems all these destroyed
stars and everything
that was never shown to have been undone
so what do you mean she saved the entire
universe she saved what a third of it at
best can we get an acknowledgement of
either that being the case or why it
isn't one of those two please don't move
forward as if everything was fixed when
you didn't actually do that
more of an issue with coming off the
previous series then with this episode
specifically but it still annoyed me
i did not like that sarah kind of had to
talk
the doctor into saving nick because
actually that was a very cool thing that
sarah realized that because the time was
shortening and nick was the first one to
die every time that they didn't have
until midnight to save nick that the
loop that they were in the next one was
going to start after the point at which
he had already died so they needed to
figure out how to get him to survive
otherwise he was going to be gone from
this whole thing that was a kind of a
cool realization
but
it sat really wrong with me that it was
like sarah had to talk the doctor into
rescuing nick
because it means one of two things
it either means that a normal human
being
who has never been in this situation
before figured out a timely whimey thing
before the doctor and that i i'm not
going to say it's impossible but they
definitely didn't fully justify that and
i have a hard time believing it
however
the way the moment is played
more strongly implies
that the doctor already realized this
but was going to ignore the problem and
let nick die
and i have a
big
big problem with that
especially given that this is the same
doctor who had this whole speech about
how they had to save person shelly and
how important he was
the doctor should feel that way about
everybody
nobody is disposable
and like granted i haven't done my
re-watch yet for um
the 13th doctor stuff but this is
something i'm going to be keeping an eye
out on
there's something like just thinking
back on it it feels like she has allowed
people to be more disposable than the
doctor ever should and that moment like
really landed badly for me
thankfully like she did go with her to
try and figure out and like she didn't
she wasn't like we can't do anything and
leave them behind like
she she did try and help but the fact
that it implies that she wasn't going to
and that the episode doesn't have time
to address why that's the case because
you can do that with the doctor you can
have moments like the 11th doctor in
um the girl who waited making the
decision to not take old amy on board
but if you're going to do that you have
to grapple with it not just imply that
the doctor was going to leave somebody
behind and then not address it
and this kind of does that i feel like
their re-entry into the tardis was
pretty anticlimactic because it felt
like
all of that buildup just to get it back
to normal
i suppose the intention was that we were
supposed to feel like oh the that that
we were losing the tardis and it was
coming apart and crumbling over the
course of flux the problem is that was
such a tiny part of all of the stuff
going on in flux not to mention they
didn't even really properly tie that
into that story just seemed to be a
thing that was happening so i suspect
what the triumphant moment was supposed
to be was look it's back the way we love
it now and it's no longer falling apart
the way that we saw them grapple with
except you know that was never a major
part of flux it was an aspect of it but
the characters barely had time to deal
with the fact that the tardis was
getting screwed up much less the story
or the audience having time to deal with
it
so it doesn't feel like a triumphant
moment it feels like a big build up to
yeah we know that set it's the same set
we've seen already i was kind of
expecting it to be a redesign which on
the one hand wouldn't really make sense
because jody whittaker is not planning
on staying on nor is chibnall so it's
probably gonna get a redesign for the
next doctor
but
that's just what it felt like they were
building up to
and they don't do it and finally uh okay
so we gotta talk about yaz and the
doctor and yes his feelings for her
uh
this
this feels like it's trying to pay off
or bank on build up that has not really
been there
there's been speculation
in the fandoms
definitely that this was something that
was going to happen some people even
calling for it outright i have my own
mixed feelings about it but that's
because i have mixed feelings about the
idea of the doctor
getting involved in romantic
entanglements anyway even if they are
only one way and coming from the
companion it's just not something i love
but
this feels like
it's trying to be a culmination
of something that had very little
concrete foundation like there were
little bits that you could read
possibly
as yeah as having a crush on the doctor
but this is like the first real solid
confirmation and we've only got to have
a couple more episodes after this in
which to deal with all that
that's
as a moment in and of itself in terms of
the interactions between yaz and dan
it's decently done
and i think i got some of yaz's
frustration the way the doctor felt like
she was going to start to open up and
then close down again
that's another part of the problem
though this doctor has been so
inaccessible emotionally to her
companions and even for yaz who's been
there the longest that it also feels
like really
what is this crush based on
she does not open up to you
you do not know her very well she hasn't
let you know her very well yes i know
crutches can be superficial not based
off deep knowledge but it
that's that's something that happens in
reality but it's not satisfying as a
narrative it's not satisfying as a story
so
i don't think it's an inherently bad
idea you know my own distaste for
romantic subplots aside i just
i don't know this does not feel like it
was developed to get to this point even
though the actual execution of this in
and of itself is okay it's just on a
foundation that is flimsy and possibly
non-existent
so
that should probably balance out
all my praise that i had earlier but
honestly
i had a lot of fun with this
i enjoyed the characters the new and the
old i liked the dynamic of everybody
involved i like the use of the daleks uh
it was a little odd that it felt like
the reveal of this was happening because
of the tardis was held for as long as it
was he's like is anybody surprised by
that i kind of assumed that was the case
right from the get-go but
whatever last nitpick i think uh but
overall i had fun with this i consider
this to be one of chibnall's better
episodes as far as the ones that he's
written by himself
so
take that as a qualified compliment
which
you know whatever but i didn't come away
from this frustrated i didn't come away
from this annoying i didn't come away
from this going oh for god's sake and we
get the sea devils next time i've been
waiting on a return for the sea devils
so i'm down for that we'll see what we
get
but yeah there's issues
but i had fun
eve of the daleks what you think about
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it like share subscribe got the
patreon that's how i pay my bills and
i'm able to keep this entire operation
up and running rewards for every tier of
support there's also a link for that in
the description plus links for other
stuff besides if you want to check me
out on twitter or twitch or instagram or
what have you plus my p.o box address if
you're feeling like you want to send me
something hey
always happy to get stuff
but that is enough of me shilling for
myself because at the end of the day my
friends you are the council i just run
the meetings so until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
none of this would have been possible
without my supporters over on patreon in
particular i want to thank robin powell
raven mcbain tracy scrabbit vincent paul
bartolucci robin moore and shayla
gourley if you'd like to hear me
possibly mispronounce your name maybe
consider looking at the reward tears
over on the patreon
but either way don't worry about it too
much
take care of yourself
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]